Speaker 1: All right, welcome, everybody,
let's jump right in, we haven't done a good
old fashioned a press briefing, wacky questions
segment in a little bit. I checked in on the press
briefing that took place on Wednesday this week
and some really pretty wacky stuff is going on.
First of all, Fox News's Peter Doocy is still
trying to ask these gotchas of Jen Psaki. She's
actually increasingly well-prepared to handle
them. And here is one where, after some comments
Joe Biden made, Peter Doocy is asking whether
if a parent doesn't like their kids curriculum,
they should be considered a domestic terrorist.
Extremely misleading. I'll explain in a moment.
Speaker 2: Does the administration agree that
parents are upset about their kids curriculums
could be considered domestic terrorists?
Speaker 3: Well, let me unravel this a little
bit because the National School Board Association
is not a part of the U.S. government. I'd point
you to them. What the Department of Justice
said in a letter from the attorney general
is that quote Threats against public servants
are not only illegal. They run counter to our
nation's core values. That is true. These
were threats against public servants.
Threats against members of the school board,
regardless of the reasoning, threats and
violence against public servants is illegal.
Speaker 1: Now you might be wondering what on
earth is Peter Doocy talking about? And what
he's talking about is the mobilization of the
federal government to some degree, on the basis
of escalated threats against educators and the
insanity that's happening at the school board
meetings. The problem is not taking seriously
the behavior of parents at school board
meetings. That's what we should be doing.
The problem is that the school board meetings are
getting completely insane, and what this entire
thing is in reference to is that last week, the
National School Boards Association pressed Biden
for federal assistance to review whether violence
and threats against public school officials
could be considered a form of domestic terrorism
and hate crimes. That's all that this is about.
And Peter, do you see, of course, has
to make it the most melodramatic thing
possible? Then Peter Doocy tries to make it a free
speech issue. The problem is lunatic parents at
the school board meetings. Then Doocy tries to
make it a free speech issue. Does Biden support
the right to protest? Of course he does.
Speaker 2: Does the president support
the fundamental right of these
parents to protest at school work?
Speaker 3: Of course, but he doesn't stand for
the fundamental right. I assume you don't, either.
For people to take violent action
against members of public servants.
And that's what the threats are about. And
so, no, he doesn't stand for that, right?
Speaker 1: It's one of these after another, after
another, just continuing to make something not
out of nothing, but make something out of what you
should be making the opposite out of. Why are all
of these parents losing their minds, going crazy
at school board meetings, attacking teachers,
verbally assaulting, quoting Hitler? As we talked
about last week on and on and on, that's really
the question. And then just one other. Here's a
bonus one. This is a different reporter saying
Why hasn't Joe Biden called Mitch McConnell
to try to get all of this stuff sorted out?
Referring to the bills and the double
standard here is notable. Let's listen first.
Speaker 2: Why wouldn't the president given
that relationship he has with McConnell,
just call Mitch McConnell and have this
conversation with him? Why do this?
Speaker 3: What's the conversation about?
Speaker 2: I don't know. They have the
relationship. He's the one who said you could
bring the two sides together. So wouldn't there
be some value in having that conversation?
Speaker 3: Know what the we know what the
risk free option is here. We know what the clear
path forward is here. And I think the president
has made no secret about his belief on that.
Speaker 1: So I have no problem with Joe.
I've said it a million times when Joe Biden
brought Republicans to the White House and some
some people on the left are mad. Some people
on the right were mad. Great. Bring them give
them an opportunity to weigh in on the COVID
stimulus bill that was back then. They don't
want to participate. Let them not participate.
And ultimately, that's what they did. But you're
not going to hold things up. It's fine to talk
to them when it was Trump. Right? The question
was why won't Democrats give Trump what he wants?
Why are Democrats getting in the way? Why won't
they concede anything at all? Why? Why? Why, even
though that was a completely dishonest framing?
Now, much of the corporate media has switched to
why isn't Joe Biden talking to more Republicans
before? The problem was Democrats weren't giving
Trump what he wanted. Now, the problem is Joe
Biden hasn't called Mitch McConnell, but a couple
of months ago, when he actually did meet with
Republicans, then the problem was why is he giving
Republicans so much power, even though he didn't?
It's the need to constantly create the most
salacious possible narrative, even if it has
very little bearing on reality. So that's the
press briefing. Let's now talk about Christmas.